lols lols lols lols bowled it amazeballs
amazeballs
[Music]
okay benedict cumberbatch loose winter
Nia how do you pronounce your full name
backwards yes I'm a cobbler dictabird I
think that was probably correct is a hot
dogger sandwich and in my house a hot
dog is a dog that's really hot can you
do an impression of Donald Trump whoever
that is
at a grocery store oh god oh okay Oh
Carlo
oh yeah okay Bible
and that is the correct answer okay if
Beyonce granted you three wishes what
would they be to watch her making one of
her videos
these are serious answers actually to be
near the front of an audience watching
out at one of our live shows but also to
somehow remain anonymous bubble that
would be having and then thirdly our
three wishes granted I was asking too
much of even Beyonc I would say maybe to
teach me at any one of our dance moves
that's the correct answer
how would you describe the taste of
water or water if you're from this part
of earth I would describe it as a
slightly wet test maybe moist
maybe a kind of hydrated taste if you
had to rename yourself what name would
you choose
Derk carful if you had to rename
yourself one day would you choose I do
have a synchronous flange placket but
most people even clear if you could make
one celebrity President of the United
States of America who would you choose
John Stewart I'd say John Stewart I
don't wanna miss celebrity sister
finish this sentence if Tilda Swinton
were an animal she would be a larger
that's a real compliment okay wicked
that's amazing finish this sentence
Benedict Cumberbatch smells like blank
and blank smell like napalm in the
morning
no you smell like like tomorrow in my
mind
wow that's the correct answer
Aska an arrow with blanket pointing to
which my face is right now it's sold